the t-pain big-ass chain is horrible
that chain right there I got more Texas
and emails than I've ever gotten before
when he unleashed that chain upon us it
is a big-ass chain that chain is what
ruins he paying for all of us and I love
t-pain
don't ever do that again that thing is a
monster
I've never seen him wear that was eyes
in this one picture in that one
performance it looks extremely heavy
that's very Kanye West of him to do so
of course it's not a day-to-day thing is
one of the performance pieces more of
you know stage attire but he definitely
made the statement that he was trying to
make Kim made him take it off probably a
the type of garfield' those are from the
darker days we can't say man we won't
see him again
I made that piece you did yes this is an
interesting fun unique piece that he did
to earlier on in his career the eyes
light up he use orange sapphires with
all gold put around it's completely 3d
so it's definitely a statement piece and
less of a fashion piece
I missed the Waka Flocka my BJ it kind
of fit his personality because he was
you know very animated very all over the
place they look alike that signified
kind of where he was at at that point in
time he was no sort of a character in
his music in the best possible way of
course but during that area that's what
people a lot of guys in hip-hop
awareness particularly love the rappers
coming from down south amigos you see
chains those are very loud very I go to
the mall in Atlanta Lenox Mall very very
Linux mall True Religion has a sale we
bought to buy the whole store everybody
loves you Jesus piece you have to bring
that back jay-z's a less-is-more type
character as well you'll never see jay-z
doing too much yeah he's never gone
overboard with the chains but he is also
somebody that commands trends and sets
trends this is
money bag chain this is something
synonymous with hip-hop along with the
Jesus piece that chain is symbolized the
best era of little Wayne getting to wear
that every day that's really when he
moved towards the forefront that's faith
little Wayne as we like to call it Burt
man give him his money back please
I was a great time in my life that was
my that was my youth rose on top of the
world especially being from Long Beach
to all the DJ's doing Snoop Dogg I saw
him at a Long Beach Poly game wearing
that chain once a skateboard and he fell
ill my friends like I wonder how much
time would cost to fix but my reply was
you know if he bought it I'm pretty sure
he can fix it it is it looks obscene in
person I've seen him a couple times
where he looks crazy in person it's well
made well done and he does it with taste
which man once said it's the crazy man
with the crazy chains and he's lived up
to that his entire life
it's his seventeen pieced ice cream
piece the bar sips in peace Gucci Mane
is one of those people who you know does
what he has to do you know he is a
standout individual so when I see that I
see something that probably only Gucci
bag could pull off